what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
alright so I haven't really done a video
like this in a long time and in truth
this video is not my normal style simply
because of the fact that I like focusing
on story arcs now and doing explanations
and different concepts every so often
also that's because of the fact that I
think I ran through all the good stuff
pretty early on in my channel and so I
feel like I should have spaced it out
more but um in this video we're gonna be
talking about the top 5 most powerful
non convict beings from Marvel Comics
meaning we're leaving out cosmic
entities um so like the Living Tribunal
eternity infinity the one above all
they're all left out the kicker about
this is there's still some stupidly
powerful like reality war burrs and
characters out there who are insane in
terms of their scale of power now this
is actually to the second side of a coin
for those guys who don't know comics
Torian had lost his voice for a while
and so he wasn't able to record a lot of
content and so he reached out to the
weekly pool of said hey guys send me
stuff and we're friends I was like yeah
of course man I'll send you some stuff
so over on his channel over a comic
story in which you'll find on Thursday
you will see a I guess the top 5 most
powerful beings in DC comics so ah with
regards to Marvel this is this is kind
of a mixed bag and so starting off our
list I guess at number 5 would be the
Scarlet Witch now as a general concept
The Scarlet Witch is not one of the most
powerful beings in the Marvel Universe
and in existence she was the most
powerful being for a very short amount
of time she was very very powerful
during the events of house of M when she
created the house of an event now the
kicker to this is that she wields what's
called Chaos magic now the funny thing
about this is that in Avengers number
502 through 504 something like that
maybe 503 ah we had Doctor Strange who
was basically talking about the idea of
Scarlet Witch Doctor Strange said no no
chaos magic does not exist
chaos magic is something that's not true
but what we learned in the Mighty
Avengers I think was volume 1 or volume
2 issues 21 through 23 is that chaos
magic does exist that there was a guy
named C'thun and that he was this elder
God to basically rule the world to the
use of
chaos magic but his reign was so dark
and it was so extreme that the those
individuals who were able to control
magic at the time it basically sealed
him away and then wiped his existence
from the history books and so as a
result Chaos magic became something of a
legend that no one knew about no one
really believed existed some other time
Doctor Strange became the sorcerer
supreme it was considered nonsense it
was considered an age-old concept that
wasn't true is more or less online of
like stories and different things like
that now while she was able to wield
chaos magic which is a fraction of the
power the C'thun has the Scarlet Witch
was stupid powerful what House of M
initially happened and after the House
of M ended and she stripped 98% in a
mutant population of their powers
initially it was believed that it was
just the main Marvel Universe but there
was actually a story I want to say was
beast then it come out and said it after
analyzing the multiverse he came to the
realization that the Scarlet Witch
stripping 98% of the mutant population
of their powers was across the
multiverse it wasn't just the main
Marvel Universe 98% of mutants lost
their powers across the entire
multiverse and Marvel Comics and that's
the reason why were putting her at
number 5 is because of that one singular
thing that one singular point in her
character's history now if we were to
take the entire history of Scarlet Witch
and we were to put her up against a lot
of people she wouldn't make the list not
by a longshot but because I wanted her
to be on here we're going with this one
moment in her publication history now
coming in at number four on our list is
Matthew Molloy now Matthew Molloy is a
character that I've done a video on a
lot of people have seen it as Scott like
a million views or something like that
like you guys love it
Matthew Malloy was Brian Michael Bendis
creation and it was it was really just
kind of like a trump card um Matthew
Malloy was originally a student that had
been discovered by Charles Xavier and
had the ability to warp reality on an
extreme scale he was beyond Franklin
Richards in the sense that Matthew
Malloy could resurrect the dead but the
kicker here is that his power to warp
reality was not inherent to himself it
was basically his ability to draw on
energies from another dimension and then
use those energies for whatever it is
that he wanted to do the problem was he
was unstable he didn't know how to
control his powers he didn't know how
they worked and in fact Charles Xavier
actually blocked Matthew was knowledge
of being able to use his powers so that
he grew up not knowing what it was that
he was capable of doing now during the
story the last will and testament of
Charles Xavier
this basically focused on this it
focused on the revelry
that Matthew Malloy was in existence the
fact that he couldn't control his powers
and how dangerous he had become and so
ultimately the x-men were forced with
the only way to defeat him to basically
go back in time and prevent him from
being born that was the only way to beat
him his powers were that extreme they
couldn't defeat him by conventional
means they couldn't suppress his
abilities they literally had to keep him
from being alive they had to wipe him
from the face of existence um now there
was some people that said this is kind
of lazy riding I agree to an extent um
but when we're going through a list like
this all we can really do is go on what
what took place in the comics if we were
to form our own opinions you know and go
based on our own individual thoughts
well then you know it would create a
whole different kettle of beans but the
fact remains here that with regards to
Matthew Malloy the faculty was able to
warp reality in such an extreme he could
resurrect the dead he could bring
himself back from the dead um the fact
that he was so capable of doing the
things that he could do that he
threatened all existence in the universe
ultimately meant that or at least to me
anyway throws him in number four just
because of the fact that he's so
dangerous now coming in at number three
this is actually a personal favorite of
mine
number three is Mad Jim Jasper's no
magic Jasper's has a huge history when
I'm really huge but he's got a pretty
significant history in Marvel Comics so
winding back to the 1970s or so whenever
it was we had a lamorne Allen Davis who
were writing the Captain Britain stories
it was literally Marvel's attempt to
branch into the United Kingdom with
comic books and so they said well why
not give you another king of her own
hero and call him Captain Britain the
kicker to this was that his first
adventures or one of his first major
adventures saw him being transported to
earth 2:38 now for those of you guys who
don't know and those were guys who were
really familiar with with numerical
designations bear with me for a second
for those of you guys who are new to
Marvel Comics alternate realities have
numerical designations and it just makes
it easier to one over the story instead
of saying like you know the ultimate
universe we can say like earth 16 10
most people say ultimate universe but
it's designated earth 16 10 the main
model continuity is earth-616
Marvel just arbitrarily assigns numbers
now this is starkly different from DC DC
takes a more linear approach so you have
earth 1 or 2 or 3 or 4 so on and so
forth then you have like earth s 4
Shazam and so on and so forth but the
idea here is that the numerical
designations help to differentiate the
different realities from one another so
that we know what stories are what what
timeline these stories are taking place
in now when the earth 238 online
Majumdar's was a
with extreme abilities to work reality
and what he had done is he had basically
created a being known as the fury and
the fury was like this cyborg entity
that could adapt to any any power that
was used on it and you know magic
Jasper's used the fury to basically kill
off all the superheroes on that earth
because he didn't want any competition
he wanted to be the most powerful being
in existence and so because of this
because there were no superpowers there
was a group called the omniversal
development court I believe and the
omniversal development court served the
purpose of basically making sure that
the evolution of realities were all on
an even scale meaning that when mutants
evolved in one universe that they also
evolved around the same time in all the
other universes and so because of the
fact that there were no mutants on this
planet in the earth 238 reality the Omni
versatile development Corps decided to
basically jumpstart mutant evolution
well in response to this Jim Jasper's
initiated what was called the Jasper's
Wharf now the reason why we put in a Jim
Jasper's at number 3 here is because the
Jasper's work was literally just an
imitation of energy coming from him to
basically spread throughout the universe
and it warped reality in the extreme
like it physically bent buildings and
changed people from solid to liquid
forms I mean it created all kinds of
different crazy things the problem with
this was at the Jasper's Wharf was so
powerful that if threatened to spill
over into all the other universes in the
multiverse and so the only thing that
the omniversal Development Court could
do was wipe his reality out they had to
literally eliminate his reality in its
entirety to save the multiverse now the
story of Captain Britain continued on in
the main Marvel Universe in earth-616
and we learned that he you know him
being assigned to go against Matt Jim
gaspers from Earth 238 was a test it was
basically him learning what it was that
Jim Jasper's could do and the reason why
was because earth-616 had his own man
Jim Jasper's who is more powerful than
his earth 238 version now this
ultimately led to a fight between you
know the the main Marvel Universe Jim
Jasper's and the fury which had escaped
you know that that destroyed universe
and arrived in the new one but the
reason why I put him at number three is
because unlike other people who can warp
reality where we see them you know
changing things or maybe modifying
things or resurrecting the dead Jim
Jasper's actually changed the universe
around him to the point where he changed
his own physical structure he made
himself into a giant monster he changed
the landscape around him
he would he would alter the perception
of beings around him like know for
example when Captain Britain walked into
the office of the Prime Minister which
is where Jim Jasper's was residing when
he opened the door he found himself in
this massive empty space of stars and
galaxies and Jim Jasper's had taken on
this weird crazy form where he was
gigantic um it was insane the kind of
things that he was doing in Marvel
Comics we've never seen reality warping
on a scale like that before and so for
that reason I went ahead and threw him
at at number three now number two is the
molecule man Owen Reese now I imagine by
this point people are like you made
molecule man number two like one why is
it Franklin Richards on this list and to
who's number one ah Franklin Richards is
not on this list because he's just not
as powerful as some of these people this
shows you the level of power that they
have when it came to the molecule man
Owen Reese he has a weird situation I've
got a video on him doing a full
explanation but of what used with this
video be if I didn't tell you about him
so within Marvel comics we of course
have the beyonders we have these beings
that exists beyond the multiverse now we
also left them out because they're like
trump cards um it would be unfair like
they would easily be in the number one
spot and it wouldn't make things
interesting so the Beyonder is hailing
from the beyond verse have insane
amounts of power they literally wiped
out all the cosmic entities during
Jonathan Hickman's run of Avengers and
New Avengers it was a sight to behold
with that particular part of the story
was it was incredible but within the
Marvel Universe of the like the
different universes in the Marvel
multiverse we have were called cosmic
cues now cosmic cubes are basically
wishing boxes is really all they are
when a person creates a cosmic cube they
can just make whatever they want reality
regardless of whether it defies the laws
of physics or not but the way cosmic
cubes work is a person basically opens a
portal to the realm of the beyonders and
they pull in a fraction of the beyonders
power and then it gets encased inside of
a cube now different realities to pick
these different ways we saw that in
infinity war that not every universe has
a cube as a cosmic cube sometimes it's
like a cosmic diamond or something like
that but it just takes on a different
form but they all pretty much serve the
same purpose the idea here was that with
the molecule man Owen Reese when he
initially performed the experiment that
gave him his powers he had basically
gone through the process of creating a
cosmic cube the problem here was that
instead of the energy of the beyonders
going into a box half of the energy went
into him
the other half just kind of floated out
into the universe until it became
sentient and then it became the Beyonder
and that's where the original 1984
Secret Wars event comes from and that's
why molecule man Owen Reese and the
Beyonder are equal in power because they
basically are the same power source
they're basically the same thing the
reason why this is such a big deal
though is because the molecule man Owen
Reese is not limited by anything if it
exists if it is something that is in
existence he can manipulate it if it's
composed of molecules really if it
exists because everything that exists is
composed of atoms which in turn make up
molecules and so he can manipulate the
fabric of everything and it made him
wildly powerful he was Beyond The Living
Tribunal he was probably second to the
one above all if not equal to the one
above all in power uh he and the
Beyonder went you know toe-to-toe
against one another when they were
during the the second secret Wars event
which saw the beyond are returning to
Earth and so on but before he was retcon
when his powers were reduced he was it
was insane he was a multiversal threat
he was a being that could traverse the
multiverse he could control the
multiverse he could do anything he
wanted to do with his powers it even got
so extreme to the point that he didn't
want to do anything he was like well if
I can do everything there's no point in
doing anything and so he just settled
down with a quiet life and that was it
he just used his powers to manifest
whatever he needed at any one particular
point in time now number one is a super
obscure character unless you read the
original guardians of the galaxy comics
which dealt with like the guardians of
the galaxy and like the year 3000 or
something like that you would not know
who this is but the number one person on
our list is a character named protege
now protege is this kid is not it's
stupid how powerful this kid is with
most most people who have extreme
abilities their abilities are part and
parcel to themselves you know for
whatever reason molecule man Owen Reese
has a power of the beyonders basically
Scarlet Witch has chaos magic Franklin
Richards has the cosmic control rod or
the powers of the cosmic control rod
essentially the power cosmic inside of
him now with protégé it's not that way
with his character he's part and parcel
to a group called the universal Church
of truth in Marvel Comics we have a
being known as The Magus and the Magus
is like the evil persona of Adam warlock
it's like Adam warlocks arch-nemesis and
he's appeared off and on he was the main
protagonist in infinity war different
things like that but um the universal
Church of truth was designed to be like
this universe wide Church the different
here
that this story takes place in the earth
691 continuity a whole different reality
here but when the universal Church of
truth had come into existence in that
universe it was looking for God to
worship the problem was that there was
no one that could live up to the
standards of the universal Church of
truth so they decided to make their own
and so what they did is they basically
took all the powers I guess all the
magics of these different races from
across the universe they molded them
into a singular being and that being was
born as protege now the reason why
protege is number one here is because
within himself protege doesn't
inherently have powers instead what
protege does is he copies the powers of
anyone he sees if they use them and so
it got to the point where this character
where he was able to copy the powers of
the Beyonder in the earth 691 continuity
the beyond are used his abilities and
then as soon as he used them protege
knew what the abilities were and had the
same powers as the Beyonder it even got
so extreme that the Living Tribunal
stepped in because protege represented
an imbalance in the cosmos The Living
Tribunal stepped in and tried to defeat
protege and protege saw the powers of
the Living Tribunal and had those powers
and so in effect anyone that shows up
and fights Protege using any measure of
power will be defeated because protege
will know how to use them and how to
conquer them with those powers it's it's
it's it's the most ridiculous trump card
in the history of comic books the result
of this is that there was a celestial
name skatin the approver now skated the
approvers weird he is he's basically a
way for Marvel to write themselves out
of a hole his powers are enigmatic at
best I did my Marvel hierarchy and that
was just one instance of you know what
it is that made scathing the approver
powerful but the idea here is it's key
thing exists to judge situations he's
basically there to say I approve or I
disapprove and it Lisa seemed as though
he has whatever power he needs to
confine a situation or to bring that
situation back to order
this is enigmatic and it's just kind of
out there it's ambiguous at best but
during the original Protege story schism
the approver had disapproved of protege
and intern had temporarily stripped
protege of his powers which allow the
Living Tribunal to step in and confine
the protege so that he basically be held
prisoner for all of eternity now of
course we know his secret Wars all that
was wiped out and the Protege has never
been seen or heard from again
so approach is probably not existed here
but at the very least we throw him in
the number one spot or I'm throwing him
in the number one spot because if a
person has
abilities and they use them Protege will
be able to copy them it's it's not so
but if you guys have suggestions or if
you guys have your own thoughts on who
should have been on this list feel free
to post them down below if you guys are
like no Franklin Richard should have
been on this list you know Franklin
winter should have been there then feel
free to post that down in the comments
if you think that you know somebody else
should have been there
you know Doctor Strange should've been
on this list feel free to post that as
well and yeah so we're gonna go ahead
and wrap this video up and if you got
your new here to comment explained be
sure to hit the subscribe button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video drop a like and I will
catch you all later
Oh follow me on Twitter come let's
explain at cam let's explain follow me
on Twitter and uh yeah I will catch you
all later peace